عمليه روسيا العسكريه في اوكرانيا نقطه
البدايه بوتن يامر بارسال قواته واليات
ثقيله الى دومباس
الحادي والعشرين من فبراير 2022 بوتين
يعترف باستقلال دوناتسك الانفصاليتين
في الثاني والعشرين من فبراير بايدن يؤكد
بدايه غزو لاوكرانيا
بعدها بيوم اوكرانيا تعلن حاله الطوارئ
على مستوى البلاد
في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الساعه
الخامسه فجرا بتوقيت اوكرانيا بوتين
يعلنوا بدء عمليه عسكريه خاصه شرقي
اوكرانيا بعد دقائق سمع دوي في جارات في
كييف وخركيف واوداسا و دومباس في الساعه
السادسه و 48 دقيقه صباحا مركبات روسيه
عسكريه دخلت الى اوكرانيا عبر سنغاف كات
وقبل الساعه السابعه صباحا زيلينسكي يعلن
الاحكام العرفيه في اوكرانيا ويامر الجيش
بالحاق اقصى الخسائر بالغزات هكذا كانت
البدايه والحرب مستمره منذ عام